it's on no definitely more babies in the
future we got an album
and then yeah more babies for sure well
they weren't joking
ashley simpson and evan ross just
welcomed a baby boy
it just kind of happened naturally the
famous couple are already proud parents
to five-year-old daughter jagger
and ashley's eleven-year-old son bronx
who she shares with ex-husband
pete wentz i've just been being a mom
and
loving every bit of it the 35 year old
singer announced she was expecting back
in april
posting a photo of her and evan posing
with a positive pregnancy test
and the caption we are pregnant and we
are so excited to share it with everyone
baby number three evan shared the same
photo
writing the fam is growing ash and i
can't wait to welcome
the newest addition it was such a great
surprise so yeah we're all so excited
in may ashley revealed their baby's
gender with this sweet family reveal how
can everyone see
okay
[Applause]
it's been great we're having so much fun
and if there's one thing i know
yeah i know
ashley and evan tied the knot in august
2014.
i don't know what i would have done she
changed definitely like more kids in the
future
a kid another kid i want five more she
said
they welcomed their daughter the
following year and in 2018
they opened up to et about the
challenges of parenthood
the time the the balance the getting you
know the time schedule everything yeah
the scheduling because kids are already
on a schedule enough so i think the
whole schedule has been
my biggest calendar whatever i'm trying
to say challenge
but it's a challenge they seem to
happily accept
the simpson rosses stick together no
matter what
you're asking me if i love you i do
i do i do their 2019
ashley plus evan tour was a family
affair
we're bringing the family on the road
everybody's coming here even their date
nights seem to turn
into a group outing what is a typical
date night we like taking the kids out a
lot of the time
yeah um we do do our day we might do
like a staycation at a hotel
yeah yeah like a one night away
every night's a date night we're
together what's not to love about this
adorable family of five
it's all that stuff yeah yeah feeling
free to love the person you love
like i feel like even whenever you know
we fell in love like i do feel like
you know you made me feel like a new
person
oh well good congratulations to the
proud parents
you